hipster individus qui souhaitent
volontairement se démarquer des autres
en adoptant une attitude qui se veut
branché cool et chic iznogoud suis en
train de nous préparer un petit before
d'apéro à base de tomates cerises tu
m'en diras des nouvelles ou non
je me suis coupé ça pisse le sang je
vais crever c'est excellent timing au
patois ont fait voir à quoi ça where
fait encore comme ça ouais encore comme
ça alors je suis en train de me vider tu
veux pas un funambule ans attend on ne
peut pas d'abord qu'on organise un petit
dernis âge
j'adore le concept ah ouais mais
excellent s'agit là talent mais au gouda
qu'est ce que tu nous a mijoté de bon
écoutez un peu charrette et donc j'ai
fait ce que venus sur le pouce
donc si un fier de l'as cannes et vaty
cuisine et la sauce citronnelle à nord
est devrait la panure de guérande
j'adore waouh c'est excellent
et normes tu abordes on échange
j'adore le concept 100 m dos où ça vient
de californie avant nice d
attends là je comprend enfin je
comprends un peu non since aurait tenu
top secret tu viens de recevoir un vide
par sms est là d'après google maps
on devrait être à reese est carrément un
problème en soi c'est pas du tout ici
soit on est carrément en avance à moins
que non là d'un concept
ouais c'est clairement un excellent
j'allais accoucher c'est l'heure de la
sieste battante à dérange pas on peut
s'en occuper même carrément tu dois en
avoir marre t'inquiète pas on gère bien
de fuir à temps
je les entends les arts qui nous attend
si tu nous entends pas tu te rends tu es
l et pas très réceptive à now with the
winter of hawaii bill clinton mais
gloria me by death and a few weeks
elle parle pas elle parle pas anglais a
autant pour moi c'est ridicule elle
parle quelle langue du coup j'adore ce
bpm race est excellent [ __ ] mais c'est
qui ce mec je sais pas qui c'est mais me
faut son album clairement le conseil
c'est un barbecue
ouarf ok wawa yake des hipsters
alors moi je traîne pas et les hipsters
est mort je préfère encore aller au
badaboum se mutile ward dans le texte
agréé notre ère mais beaucoup se
prennent quoi vous aider
yes ouais je recherche de café bio un
décaféiné
évidemment il sud agriculture
coopérative et si possible avec un petit
goût mentholé du témoin ouais ou à du
thé du thé mais alors sans théine alors
il ya peut-être quelque chose qui
pourrait vous convenir soir il n'y a pas
de café il n'ya pas tes qui est qui est
très bien c'est l'eau chaude
bonsoir monsieur je peux vous aider
ya pas d je peux vous aider ou quoi que
ce soit vous savez pas qui on est on a
un bloc donc on était calmes toi came
down
ah voilà on est sur liste au nom
d'iznogoud des cas min on a invité par
cassiopée voilà désolé monsieur n'a pas
dit si si c'est une anthony président a
ok je veux le délire c'est une soirée
open entre et j'adore les concerts
ans
dubois gloria s'émeut prospective de
rohmer au maire un génie du cinéma on
peut le dire ouais bon ben là c'est
clairement une scène un peu porn
c'est sympa la nouvelle vague un peu cul
mais pas trop [ __ ] mais vous êtes
malade les mecs c'est une enfant bah
quoi apparemment alors le concept abonne
toi nos chaînes youtube en cliquant sur
nos [ __ ] de tête tu vas adorer n a
remis ces masses excellent vraiment un
problème de jouer la can excellent